auch die tatwaffe mordanschlags einfach
so hängen geblieben ob die dich
umbringen wollen
dazu kommen zu einem neuen video und
liebe leute ich habe vor einigen tagen
berichtet ist die rede
selbstverständlich von dem video der
erste mordanschlag hatte vorgesehen dass
begraben partner ist schon so ein spiel
komplett draußen nicht angeschaut aber
dann habe ich mich heute bekommt dabei
in der weise als der einstieg nach so
viel action hero so kommen sie zu
anderen videos und damit soll ja stimmt
eigentlich aber ich habe schon ewig ins
meer gebracht deswegen nehmen wir dieses
wunderschöne video der erste
mordanschlag gegen nicht mal ansatzweise
kommerziellen videos kurzem hat man
sieht nicht wirklich am mordanschlag auf
nach dem kopf über den zweiten wir leben
schon die bewertungen sind super 29.000
leicht zu 93 2001 lieben denn natürlich
gefreut da ist was ich gewohnt so tolle
feedback deswegen hat er auch selbst den
kommentar geschrieben und ein gewinn für
das erste positive feedback verläuft
komplett hinzugeben wo ist das positive
zieht der eu hat mehr gezeigt als leih
und das bei 333 1000 abonnenten wird
erwacht ist das ist die die krankheit
die bank biete zwei millionen
im video und gestalt und die video
ausleihe positiv und der krankheit ist
deshalb auch bereit mehrere tricks und
das mir halten sie das wetter positiv
und wahrscheinlich machen doch der zug
mit etwa aufgerufen ab und rosa vieler
werden wenn wir etwas auf nachdem er
schon die herzliche punkte in diesem
video richtig sympathisch mal und zwar
dieser mensch hat er habe auch diesem
video 123456 bescheid ist wirklich keine
zweifel dass die wirkliche welt als
gesamtwert von der biosphäre von der
beetle krankheit
das ist kennt die symptome sind klare
der dabei liegt klar auf der hand wer
dies als leicht farbe und von politik
sprechen so viele mit wort und video
parken und immer noch mehr edition die
videos ist aufgebrochen
das video hier ist ein nicht lustiges
video sondern ein werk von mir also real
man könnte auch sagen wahrheitsgetreu ob
dieses video bis zum ende bei diesem
tarif ist einfach indem du alles im
mittelrhein und private die story zu
recht ist deswegen ein schaden von
amerika draht menschen ziemlich
abstoßend
die geschichten die welt erzählt gehen
so er war eine luke feiere in diesem
klub computer zu gehen und beleidigte
ihn erst bestehenden beleidigt an und
sagt warum bleibt für mich ein content
usd und schmeißt den der in belecke
braucht und an dem abend nicht mehr
außer dafür kumpel von ihm noch am
nächsten tag wieder alle zusammen denn
deine kumpels und das mädchen das coupé
von einem ordner geschäft wurde das
mädchen wollen dass ich hier wieder
weggefahren und ein dickes mädchen dann
weggefahren haben fünf wochen fertig mit
ihrem auto drehen sich mit krippe und in
dem moment angeblich zwei autos und
keinem die einen versperren im vorn und
hinten quasi den weg und maskierte
bewaffnete menschen steigert auch aus
und ein gepflegtes auto von dennis'
koblenz kumpel gibt ein guard fährt weg
die zwei autofriedhof folgen wie dabei
außerdem bildet wirklich flüchtet pferd
angeblich mit 80 mg die straßen kommt am
ende in irgendeinem stehen die beiden
verfolger autos versperren in dem moment
die sackgasse und die jungs von denen es
schwer haben wir dann allerdings kurz
bevor sie vermeintlich gegriffen werden
kommt der familie also einen fahrer mit
frau und kinder lassen sich die
angreifer die luftfahrt mit zwei kindern
die kinder seine frau land greifen
deswegen gehen um eine über bürger die
geschichte wie möglich nach berlin
zugetragen hat
auf die kraft der geschichte ich bin in
köln über die straße gelaufen
richtigkeit
mit den kölner den schlaf geraubt hat
einmal dass wir sowas täglicher was geht
jetzt auf der anderen straßenseite ist
eine person lächelt mich einfach nicht
so voll überrascht was oma in gold pig
in meine leute schreibt also los was
geht habt ihr was teure und ich bin
einfach so glücklich lächelt nicht
zurück beste was passierte am nächsten
tag ich vor die haustür steht der typ da
bin ich nicht zurück eingeleitet habe
und hinter ihm einfach so das komplette
militär der vereinigten staaten in
unserer kleinen schrank das komplette
militär der freien staaten die gesamte
stadt verfolge mit dem auf einmal die
stelle hinter den typ also zähler hinter
energie mittelbar auch andere gibt ja so
ein zeichner verliebt hat mich zufrieden
dann habe ich ein anderes gemacht haben
konnten geschützten zurückwerfen aber
ich schwöre ich bin gern auto gesetzt
also wir sitzen grad im auto mitten auf
dem feldweg nach liebes und anmeldung
bis 10 von dem abweicht jedem video
aussieht als man sie von dem video auch
von es schwer gezeichnet von diesen
körperlichen angriff der sie einst
wirklich schwer verwundert hätte ich
gerne noch vor die kamera quervergleich
wartet mail mit deinem gesicht in dem
video uns auf einmal steigen die aus
ratet mal welcher typ auf einmal vor
unser auto stand und auf einmal in
voller wucht gegen die scheibe
geschlagen hat während mein kollege
drückt einfach kommt jetzt vor ausgabe
50 60 km h auf der motorhaube
mein kollege zieht einfach mal kurz
einmal nach links und schönster kommt
einfach vom auto weg geflogen
also wir haben sachbeschädigung ist auch
wenig wir haben nötigung auf jeden fall
habe auch dem 22 schwere verletzungen
natürlich gehen auch wenn bei dexxit
fanden auch runter fällt das ist nicht
so angenehm länger weil sich keine
beweise
mancher und am nächsten tag findet er
uns einfach auf und wer uns keine ahnung
was die besprechen ich fand es der beute
flüchteten
ich glaube auch dass ich da auf der
ziemlich töten das ist es solche
verhältnisse jemand hat dem klub spart
und beleidigt personalern rausfliegt ist
es natürliche reaktion das personal am
nächsten tag versuche einfach umbringen
als mein leben in deutschland so
rechtsstaat im unglück steht auch die
würde des menschen unantastbar
dementsprechend angemessene reaktion
mordanschlag für das alles gesagt dass
dienste solcher zu verpissen dann kamen
wir an der hauptstraße an und auf einmal
häufig schwierig jetzt noch gänsehaut
mit meinen kollegen einfach an zu
fliegen und der typ aber deren erfolg
nicht auf einmal aus einem abend ich bin
ich höre dich soll in echt persönlich
gar keinen für business zu spielen beste
aus seinem amt und holt unsere automaten
rausgeflogen ist wieder auf den boden
zurück zuerst auf jeden fall sind geht
dann halt in dieses spiel straße
reingefahren die zwar mit tempo 80 gilt
tempo 80 ein spiel starten
das perfekte moment sagen wir bei völlig
zu recht ist die dazu zum montag einfach
der größte passagierjet und bei 10.000
sechs leute und das comedy größen buchen
würden erwarten dass diakonie geld lomas
uhr ausgeweitet bei 5000 leute die das
übertrieb ausgleich wieder ist das eine
anerkannte methode also werden die dann
wirklich zu hohen drehmoment meine
geforderte ok und zu was bist du
eigentlich denn es wird und 40.000
läufer beim video dieses leicht besser
als der unterschiedlichste egos aller
zeiten und nochmals zur infobörse man
kriegt keinen fällt mehr dadurch dass
man leicht auf dem video ist aber so gar
nicht so einfach wäre zwar 2004
eröffneten video warum ich irgendwie
scheiße gelabert das märchenhafte alle
sind wenn ich vielleicht bekommen sie
biegen rechts ab und zahlen geradeaus
durch weiter auf einmal sehen wir es ist
ein scheiß barkasse lacasse
heute stellen wir ihn vor dieser kasse
in neue art und weise in der gastronomie
abzurechnen und geld auch zu bewahren
der menschenkenner gewalt und seine
gesamten vorräte an einem roten sarg
auffange mit dem los gefahren sind und
sie hatten zu fahren wurde sie irgendwie
angerufen um geburt einfach an ihm
angerufen und gefragt wo wohnst du und
einfach aufgelegt und sie wird einfach
auch zu hause angerufen und es wird
einfach gefragt wo das mädchen wohnt
irgendwelche fänden haben fahrzeugs
einberufen welche wir wollen das wurde
mädchen wohl nicht aus aber
wahrscheinlich nicht doch niemals so ein
hobby los menschen gesehen wie vor bloß
weil ich bin dafür dass angeblich darum
die ihn umzubringen ist der junge mann
wie gesagt bei 5.000 gleich dass die
größte bausparte bei 10.000 likes dass
die allergrößten buchen sind in
deutschland das es gibt natürlich
menschen daraus ist im komplett hängen
geblieben und haben wirklich im café an
traditionen haben uns viel macht filme
geschaut denn er war aggressiv den
spielern und stellen sich so was
vielleicht wirklich nach vorn ihre
köpfchen aber dass wegen so einer aktion
wo er ja vermeiden dass überhaupt
gemacht hat so auch direkt aus dem
mafiafilm an bereich kunst gefällt ist
dass somit künftig mit grauem anzug kaum
steigen
er wirkte sehr gut platziert hat aber
das kann nicht sein und dann ist man
häufig zuletzt von ihm auch bei denen
vorgeschichte wäre zum beispiel
nachgezogen
holidaycheck mehr was passiert ist dass
die kinder vor dem typen vom club
abgefasst hatte sagt hellmers des echten
blöd machen daraus nach einem
mordanschlag zu machen ist auch klar
auch die charta von mordanschlags
einfach drin geblieben als auch die dich
umbringen wollt wenn das wirklich so
passiert ist ungefähr so als übertrieben
aber ist ungefähr so passiert ist und es
fällt nicht umbringen sondern die fläche
zeigen nicht gut fanden ganz leicht
vielleicht wie eine reihe ab september
zwei prozent an wert ist das immer noch
aus den schornsteinfegern hier wurde
angeboten wohl zusammenfassen lukas
gesagt wieder hilflos muss gestoppt
werden ich würde sagen leute bei 50.000
bis leicht auf seinem bio hat sich diese
geschichte nur ausgedacht bei netviewer
alle betrifft mir wenn ich mal vor wenn
man einige teile dieser zahl erreicht
kamera diese dislike oder leichtgewicht
der eigene klub und die kriegen dann
auch wirklich ein also ich könnte sagen
wenn ihr das video 15.000 leider
bekommen welche präsident der
vereinigten staaten und das wird auch
passieren aber marken zusammen deswegen
lassen was alle leute mit einkommen
leicht ausdrücken wie de oder com
bekommt hätte durchbricht auf rang vier
und die runden kommt